encore un jeune qui s'est apparemment
retrouvé au mauvais endroit au mauvais
moment
hier soir il est devenu la cinquième
personne tuée par balle à londres cette
année et qui est un des stades aux
olympiques jo nous faudrait il pas toi
le descriptif des compotes 8 arrête là
de news donnait donc toi qui côtoie
compliqué tu viens d'où je suis de
déport d'un aqueduc et tout va j'ai posé
la question à mon frère pourquoi peckham
déteste le gâteau si tu fiches et ce
alors tester leur 12e la donne et
beaucoup de chanteurs qui viennent de
paix qu'est mort non mais rien ne
t'empêche peut-être la première un mec
des gangs
je veux paniqué je veux seulement être
avec elle selon vous ce fait les sachets
bien légaux bits
c'est le frangin de switcher on serre
les courses protège je te protège et tu
protèges si tu avais planté moi je
l'aurais planter encore plus invité
domec moyen de peckham qu'est ce que ça
peut te [ __ ] est malade ou quoi
tu ne l'ès pas s'en tirer comme ça c'est
compris qu est ce qui t'es arrivé ton
pote a fait ça mon pote ce môme à ce
junior j'te jure que je vais lui régler
son compte
mais qu'est ce que tu veux prouver tu
sais j'suis pas avec eux tous ceux qui
sont pas avec moi c'est qu'ils sont
contre moi oublie pas ça
et maintenant tu es content mort de
personnes descendent manager et ouais
c'est mon fils qu'il s'agit je suis sa
mère et personne ne dit rien
pourquoi pour un club postale qui
m'aiment pas nous
on va pas rester là les attendre la
meilleure défense c'est l'attaqué
depuis le début tu essaies de me choper
mais là c'est moi qui vais dopé